hello everyone welcome to a video on
code tech tutorial today today i'm going
to teach you how to use openshot
so if you'll mind me stumbling over
words i'm going to do this live and try
to get in one nice take so we're looking
at open shot video editor i previously
did a video
about it about openshot video editor and
kind of reviewing it and i was maybe a
little harsh
because i actually kind of like it it's
not too bad so
this is just where you go to download
it's an open source program there's lots
of
things you can do to get it you can even
build it from source if you want
openshot.org
and pretty sure it works on every os so
just scrolling down yeah cross
platform unlimited tracks title editor
edit video trim and slice video effects
3d animations
70 plus languages animations and
keyframes audio waveforms slow motion
and time effects
simple user interface now with anything
with these many features all packed into
one thing there's always a few drawbacks
you'll have that
and i can say that most of these
features as far as i know work pretty
well
so we're gonna edit a video and i'm
gonna walk you through how to use it so
here is open shot i have launched it
and i'm gonna i'm on a new project so
i'm gonna
bring in a video and do a little quick
editing on it and just carefully walk
through everything i do and show you
what we're
what we're doing so over here on the
left side you see properties
here you have your project files which
you can change to
other stuff you're probably going to
have it on project files most of the
time though
and i'm going to have it on show all and
we have a video preview over here
we have all our timeline stuff down here
all right let me go find a video here
i'm just going to pull up my file
explorer go to my recordings
and basically just grab something um
kind of small one let's go with let's go
with this here it's only four
it's about half a gig uh here's a
smaller one
i don't know what these are exactly to
be honest so yeah let's do this 32
megabyte one so all you do is you just
drag it in
to your project files or down onto a
track if you want to be on a track right
away if you drop it here
it still goes into your project files
okay it looks like this is a little
random seven days to die game play
so i'm not sure exactly what it is
but uh that's fine that's fine for uh
doing a little example it's about
two minutes long approximately so as you
can see here
we can click on it and we can unclick on
it and when you click on it you get the
properties
now this is where you gotta be careful
because if you play with these buttons
it timelines things in uh and by so by
simple user interface
they they maybe cut out a few steps for
timelining
because for example everything's default
right now but if i go over a few seconds
and then set something like let's see
any of these locations positions
rotations anything
i can make it timeline to that so
for example give it a little rotation i
don't know
it's kind of an odd thing to do and boom
suddenly it times
lines it in linearly from right there so
at the beginning of the video
it's it's defaults as time goes on it'll
rotate to there
and then just stick and i don't know
what's going on on the video there i'm
going to turn that way down
so this is really all about the video
to be perfectly honest i've had mixed
results with the audio coming out of
open shot that might be my biggest
complaint is sometimes the audio is
scratchy and staticky especially if
there's
effects layered and stuff so audi it's
strong suit is definitely not in the
audio
it generally works fine but occasionally
it won't so just be
aware of that and if you crank up the
volume on a track it does also timeline
it in
so so one of the things is a little
tricky is if you want to affect the
whole track with something with
something like a volume increase
it doesn't let you go above one i think
it's because it clips but if you
select down here and type it in like
just a little bit louder 1.5
it puts it in on the timeline so if i
were over here and changing that
it would make the volume 1.5 here but
since i did it
at the very very beginning of the track
it just sticks for the whole track
so that's something to consider so if i
for example go to here and now i put the
volume at
one now it's going to start at 150
and then go down to one volume there
so a little bit of controls you can do
there and if you want to remove any of
these you can always
right click and remove keyframe and
right click and oh
remove keyframe so that removes the
keyframe from that on this clip you have
selected
now let's talk about splitting and
cutting a little bit
because i think you can see all the
options there and kind of probably
understand how to timeline things in a
little bit and how to undo them
so when you want to split something say
i want to cut i don't know i'm just
going to pick an arbitrary location
right here you right click on this
little node
nodule thing up here this little blue
thing
and brings up a menu a slice all
and then you can pick oh it shows you
the hotkeys so you can keep both sides
keep the left side or keep the right
side and this does exactly what you
think if i keep both sides
it keeps them both and just makes a
split but if i only if i
for example just want to cut out this
whole section right there i could now go
here and go keep left side
so i'm going to undo those ctrl z
and control z again and control z again
it looks like it does three operations
to do a
cut because i had to do undo several
times for the
for that so one undo two undos
three undues okay yeah i guess it's
three undo's to
undo a keep both sides so there's a
little bit of walkiness like that
that i'm talking about that you might
need used to but
it's kind of a small sacrifice to pay
for all the this free stuff
that you get in the general generally
working thing now i once i covered
a lot of blender video editing and those
are some of my more popular videos
but blender is not really made for video
editing it's clunky in a lot of ways you
can do a lot of cool stuff
so i'm i've been moving towards testing
out actual video editors
and they're a little bit more
user-friendly than blender blender's
still good though there's nothing really
wrong with using blender other than for
me the workflow kind of got to me after
a while because it was just
uh it would get it would get clunky
after a while but i think all videos do
that to some extent too so
you'll have that all right what else to
teach
we got the splitting we got the cutting
we got the time lining
that's like kind of the main stuff you
can bring more stuff into your
uh project here or you can always drag
in images and then
put them over here in your timeline but
you can also go up here to
title title
and you can kind of make your own titles
so this is sort of an interesting
feature
uh like you'll see
if you click on like this gold one here
you get it and you can edit
test but it's a little it's always a
little slow for me
hold on i'm going to save this project
because another thing that happens
is i'm just going to name a test demo
project
so another thing that happens is when
you save
it saves in the same directory all these
little project files
so i made a title here and now let's see
let's see if i go to it in my folder
wherever i saved all this stuff which is
i think in my users
yeah so here's an example here's test
demo project where i
saved it and then i'll also have a test
demo project assets now that goes along
with it
so it creates that folder for you as you
make videos
and then save projects so you can load
them up later and it works just like you
think
you can go to quit and then you can
reopen it
and load it right back up where you left
off that all seems to work
nice and seamless open
test demo project there we go and we're
back
so you got to make sure you click on
your clip to do stuff with it but now
now that we have a detail in here we can
go click on it and we can do that
do edit on these titles um
so you can do whatever you want with
these and
and also if you're not happy with how
these turn out
you can kind of do something special so
it kind of makes them a little longer
than i prefer so i always shorten them
and i'm going to show you another little
thing if you overlap clips it auto fades
in between them
but only to an extent so if i go like
this it now just auto fades that in
that's what that little blue thing is
see the fade happening there it's kind
of kind of lagged a little bit but
it does that with videos too so you got
to be careful because now when i take
this off it still keeps that fade there
so there's some weird stuff like that
that it tries to auto do
and now it just does something i don't
know it doesn't work right
so you got to watch out for that and if
you want to add in your own transitions
this is also a little weird because you
overlap it
then you got to delete this little blue
one and then you i'm turning my phone
off
please know every time i record gotta
remember
to just power off my phone before i hit
record okay so i drag in this transition
on top of them
but now the weird thing is you can't see
where you're supposed to stop it
to make it fade properly into the new
one it's somewhere around here
but i can't actually tell so it's like
really annoying like that
like i guess i want it to be something
like this so maybe i can drag back up
after that
and no wait wait wait that doesn't work
right because it only has to be the end
of this
so it'd be like that except it still
seems to overlap a tiny bit and i can't
get it to adjust perfect no matter what
i do so there's there we go
i had to get it to snap so that sort of
works
that might work so now we should have
this bar ripple transition which you
won't be able to see very well
there it goes but that's how you get
those to work and that's how you line
them up they're a little weird
but they do all seem to function as long
as you get this line up correctly and
you can do it
you just got to delete the default one
it gives you and then get it to line up
and then clip the video over like
like so and another annoying thing is if
you have this little
uh tracker bar next to where you're
working
it'll try to snap to it all the time and
sometimes you can't snap to your other
position very well because you're right
next to it so you just got to move
this out of the way and as you go
through and make more cuts
you can you can do little things and add
your things in
and make it flow like an actual video so
that's basically the goal here so i
don't know maybe we're cutting out a
little section there so we'll do a
keep right and then we got a little bit
more
we'll zoom back in so as you can see
this is zoom in let's
zoom out i probably should have
mentioned that earlier and we'll do
another little fade here
except you see this one didn't auto fade
and i don't know why sometimes it does
the auto fade
sometimes it doesn't i think you just
gotta overlap at a certain amount and
let's try this hatched one
so this makes a huge one by default
obviously we don't want it that big
so a lot of these defaults are way too
long to be reasonable
and that's sort of weird too so now we
gotta
drag this other one off so we can see
where it's supposed to go about right
there
get it to snap to the end and get this
to snap and boom that
that's pretty good that's about the best
you can do with the transitions
and uh usually i try to make them about
two seconds but
you can't even tell because there i was
i think i was just looking at the same
inventory the whole time so
you can't really tell the crossfade but
there's a there is a hatched fade but if
it was a more
uh extreme you would be able to tell
so there's that there's also these
effects now i haven't used these effects
a whole lot but we'll test one out you
basically apply it to a whole clip so
i'll
ready to keep both sides there i'll go
over here i'll do another keep both
sides so now i just got this
clip sectioned off and i'm going to drag
one of these in here like this
negative and i'll just drop it on top
and boom it makes the whole this whole
clip negative
so now when we go over that it'll just
be
suddenly negative so all these kind of
work like that you can play around with
those you just gotta apply them on their
own little clip
let's see what happens if i layer them
is something weird going to happen i
don't even know
because now i did pixelated and negative
and i think it seems to be kind of
working
well that's uh that's that
all right so then you can go to the end
get a little outro if you want to do a
fade out
you can use this alpha near the end or
what you can do
is right click on these files so are on
these uh
sections so another really cool thing is
if you have like a little section
let me let me just make another little
section here somewhere like maybe right
here
we'll do a keep both sides i will just
use the whole end section
this this whole inch chunk right here
i'll zoom in a little bit on it
and click on it now another thing is you
got to make sure
you can accidentally multi-select and
it'll operate on
both of them at once if you start adding
stuff hopefully
i hope that made sense so if i go and do
something over here now it's going to
operate on both clips so you want to
make sure you only have one selected
when you start doing stuff
so i got this one selected and i'm going
to right click
and i get all that you get all these
options for the clip you can copy it
you can fade it animate rotate
layout now these are all auto stuff this
is stuff you can do
otherwise with these properties but one
a couple that i really like to use are
the fades
you can do let's see like an entire clip
fade in and out
fast or slow or
end of clip fade out slow
i like to use fade in and out sometimes
if it's a clip i want to fade in and
want to fade out rather than having to
do it manually
you can just go in here and go fade in
and out
fade in fast fade in slow start so we'll
do a fade in fast
and end of clip fade out slow and there
you go you see it put the
keyframes in there and it'll do it
it's kind of lagging behind on the video
up there
there it goes all right
there we go so
that is uh it in a nutshell if you want
to get rid of those fades you can right
click and
go to no fade and they're gone with
these animations you can do the same
you can do some animations there's
they're
not that great oh you usually have to do
some customizing but as you can see it
just put some scales in there
and it's not doing it linearly it's it's
using uh what is this called
bezier so ease is in and out
so that's kind of cool that you can get
that going on as you
as you can see here it's going to do it
just to zoom in and it'll stay that way
for the rest of the clip
and another thing is if you cut after
doing that
thing it'll still apply it to the ones
after it so as you can see
this one is still scaled in you have to
go in here and go to animate no
animation
so just so you're aware
so yeah this one zooms in but once you
get to the end of this clip
and now that i reset it on this one over
here it
should zoom back out yeah let's back out
okay
and we could even do something like this
uh we can make it
blur into it which is a weird transition
but you know just for example
so it was zoomed in and then it's going
to blur back to the full one
so you can do all sorts of stuff like
that play around with these different
effects and get
different transitions there's just a lot
to do here a lot you can play around
with and the
interface is pretty quick once you get
used to the
the few oddities here and there it's
fine i will also say let's see let me go
back to project files here
you can move all these little windows
around and customize this how you like
there is some options up here for views
and you can play around with those i'm
just using the simple view but you can
go to like advanced view and you've got
a different
sort of setup where your project files
are here and your effects are here
so that's that's the thing i'm going to
go back to simple
okay simple view where's the side thing
show all okay show all is what i was
doing
okay so there's different tracks and of
course they're layered as you think
things on top will show
um things underneath will show only if
the things above
are alphaed out
um yeah you can bring audio in here it i
wouldn't recommend
this as your main audio mixing like i've
said when audio gets mixed in this
for some reason it comes out a little
staticky if you don't do anything to it
and just leave it alone it's usually
fine
but once you put some edits on it things
get a little weird i don't know
you guys will have to let me know if you
have the same experience so
i think that about covers it when you're
ready when you're ready to go and done
you just hit this record button up here
i don't know why it's a record button
it's actually an export video but it
looks like a record button
so you just hit the button you got your
file name you tell it where you want it
to go
i usually go to this rendered folder on
a different drive
and here you got all your stuff and you
see i got 1080 at 60 frames per second
pretty standard here for me but there's
a lot of other options
if you want to see those or mess around
with those and
you hit export it does its thing and
it's the way it goes
i've been able to do videos that were
like an hour too long at the most but i
once tried to render a six hour video
and it didn't work
so just fyi it you know it took me a
whole day when i got to the end it
seemed to froze
so a six hour video didn't get handled
too well
i had to eventually just crash it and
lose the project
well i had to abandon the project
because there was just no way that video
was gonna
finish rendering but it seems to do fine
with smaller ones and you know up to a
couple hours
and what else is there to say let me
know if you have questions down below
i will try to answer them i guess i'll
show you this animated title thing so
you can also make animated titles which
uses blender for yeah i'll say a few
last things before i end this
and these are hit miss so it renders
these
when if you want to use them it's like a
pre-made project where it just renders
them with blender for your project
and you have to have blender installed
these are hit and miss some of them work
some of them don't they might be version
dependent on blender
i would honestly say don't expect these
to work
if you get one to work then
congratulations but most likely they are
just going to freeze
um i think it's just a couple of them
work and the most
the other ones don't so i just kind of
gave up on those because they were
getting too clunky and i had an output
error i think it didn't see blender or
something
another cool thing is when you're doing
these titles if you have critta
installed you can you can go to one of
these and you can go to use advanced
editor
and when you click use advanced editor
it's going to launch krita with this
project
and you can make edits with krita so
that's kind of a nice little integration
there it's still launching here but
eventually it'll come up
there it is it's on my other monitor
so there it is so you can do stuff here
and whatever you want i'm just going to
do a few
just various random arbitrary things
just to show you that it works i don't
know let's get this little spray paint
get
some orange and oh okay we just painted
that in there
make a box down here i don't know why
all right
so the point is now when i hit save
and close krita this title is going to
update with what i did there in krita so
that's super cool
and you can hit save and it just comes
in your project and you can use it
just drag it in it's taking a moment's
lag and a little there we go
and you just drag it in so we'll have
that
randomly there i'm gonna make it smaller
then i'm gonna go
fade tire clip fade in and out slow
so that that's one way to just kind of
i don't know i don't know what i'm
saying in this video but
that's uh wait a minute that didn't work
too well well no fade
fade tire clip
entire clip in an in and out slow yeah
there we go i think i i think i only did
n or something
all right
that just snapped in that's supposed to
be a fade so i don't know what happened
there see there's
that's kind of another glitch there's
weird little random glitches like that
tire clip fade in and out slow so it
should fade in
and then fade out right that's that's
what you would think
there it's fading in but when it was
smaller it wasn't so i don't know
there's just some weird stuff like that
you kind of got to get used to and you
just got to test it out and make sure
it's actually going to do what you think
it's going to do
but beyond that works pretty great you
can get your videos
edited and get some some fine stuff in
there that you prefer
and do a little bit of production add a
little bit of production value i should
really do this more
um yeah i don't i don't consider myself
a video editor i just do it
out of necessity so
um i like it to be easy and i don't like
it to be too much overhead and open
shots kind of nice for that because it's
not like
a professional video editor but you can
get some basic production value without
having to gain like a major
understanding of
production so that's gonna do it for
this video hope
hopefully this answered your questions
about
open shot and maybe showed you a lot of
what it can do here
and how to do it hope you enjoyed this
walkthrough
and this uh i guess it's sort of an
updated review on openshot
don't forget to leave a like and
subscribe to this channel if you would
like to see more tutorials or just more
of me in general
because it's just me here this is my
channel
thank you for the support peace out